Hillary Clinton given her secretary of
state record has a very significant
foreign policy record that we can
actually look at and I'd say as
Secretary of State she comes down fairly
strongly as a Moneyball America
candidate I mean really focusing without
sentimentality on where America gets
value for investment it's not about
values it's not about promoting
democracy in the free market globally
it's about focusing on those issues in
those areas where the United States by
investing by spending resources by
committing people can really move the
needle for America she talks about the
pivot to Asia economic statecraft she
was the principal architect of the
trans-pacific partnership she did not
want to get bogged down by the Middle
East she focused not at all on Israel
Palestine unlike her successor John
Kerry she and Libya she was reluctant to
get involved militarily and only
supported it when it was a relatively
pinpoint series of military engagements
with no American casualties during the
military offensive and no plans for
state building or nation-building
afterwards then she launched the reset
with Russia which was really intended so
that the Americans wouldn't have to
focus so much on the country that used
to be our principal protagonist now some
of those things worked some of those
didn't work and some of those were going
to wait and see but the fact was that as
a strategy Hillary really did articulate
Moneyball I remember when she even said
on China you know it's really hard to
criticize your banker on Human Rights
that is that is a classic Moneyball
statement right it's like hey you know
we would like to talk to China about
human rights but it's not really
realistic they're too big they hold all
this cash we can't really push in that
much very pragmatic interestingly
Hillary the candidate you know is a
little bit different she's tried to back
away from the Iran deal she's backed
away from the risk aversion on Syria
she's backed away from the Russia reset
and she hasn't even said that she
supports the trans-pacific partnership
which to me is a little ludicrous
clearly she's doing that for political
reasons not for policy reason
uh it it it's disappointing I can't say
it's surprising most people that run for
president if they're credible are
inherently political and do things that
disappoint us all as human beings I
wouldn't necessarily only say that
that's Hillary it certainly found on the
Republican side too she does more of it
than many she's a Clinton but she's also
a very effective politician I I guess
what what's interesting is that so far
of course since she's declared her
candidacy over a month ago we've
actually heard very little from Hillary
she's not taken many questions again
also a perfectly good strategy if
there's no incredible running against
you on the Democratic side why would you
want to tip your hand until you know who
you think you're going to run against on
the Republican side and then shape your
answers or your message accordingly to
best be able to beat up on that person
makes sense politically doesn't inspire
as a leader right so i think the real
point on Hillary is we know she's
competent we know she's quite capable we
actually know she's got a lot of foreign
policy experience we don't really trust
her and also something a little aside
but I think it's interesting I think
isn't it as a people I think that
Americans I think we have a harder time
with women being inauthentic than we do
with men I think like Bill Clinton you
know if he would have pull off the same
stuff would be like ads just bill so
what but I mean with Hillary were like
wait a second I think there's a double
standard here I think it hurts her a
little bit and we haven't quite gotten
through it so I mean for all those
reasons kind of interesting but but
still very early days and I wouldn't
dare to make any projections on the
presidential race on the basis of what
we've seen from Hillary so far
you